there is a story that's hugely important
but not necessarily for the reasons a
lot of people think the Chinese doctor
who was the whistleblower about
coronavirus has died now immediately a
ton of articles and a ton of people
started saying or implying the Chinese
government killed the doctor and that
that's the scandal the doctor appears to
have genuinely died of coronavirus
himself which he contracted while
working at Wuhan central hospital in
China the scandal and the controversy is
that the Chinese government appears to
have sent police to tell him to shut up
about corona virus after he sent out a
warning via chat group to other doctors
on December 30th about coronavirus we're
talking about 34 year old doctor Lee wen
Yan Liang who was an ophthalmologist
noticed seven cases of a virus that
looked to him like SARS he sent the
message to doctors in a chat group
saying you should wear protective
clothing when you're with patients
four days later as reported by the BBC
he was summoned by the Public Security
Bureau where he was told to sign a
letter which accused him of quote making
false comments that had quote severely
disturbed the social order he was one of
eight people who police say were being
investigated for spreading rumors
local authorities later apologized to
him because of course he was completely
right about coronavirus but more
importantly a few days later on January
10th he started coughing then he had a
fever then he was in the hospital
diagnosed with corona virus on the 30th
of January and ultimately has passed
away so as of right now I do not believe
that the Chinese government killed him I
believe he died of exactly what he was
worried about which is coronavirus
contracted from patients the real
concern is that the Chinese government
has prioritized silencing doctors rather
than immediately moving to deal with
coronavirus and I want to be really
careful because the entire coronavirus
story has been used in some enclaves to
justify discriminatory and disguise
ding comments about Chinese people and
Chinese culture that's not what I'm
doing this is a critique of the Chinese
government
now just to circle back around to the
conspiracy theory piece that the Chinese
government killed this guy to silence
him that he didn't die of coronaviruses
of co of coronavirus i'm not blind to
the atrocities committed by the chinese
government over the last many decades
I'm not pretending they don't exist we
don't have evidence that that's what
happened so I don't believe that it is
prudent or responsible to push it now
there are some people who said you know
this guy was 34 coronavirus is really
killing little kids and the elderly how
did a 34 year old die of it that's
mostly true but there are people of just
sort of medium ages that have died of
coronavirus I'm not ignoring the
possibility that there is more to this
but right now it does not seem
responsible to push that the Chinese
government killed this guy it does seem
that the Chinese government was more
concerned with covering up the existence
of coronavirus early on then in moving
quickly and swiftly to actually deal
with it the latest numbers 38,000 cases
815 deaths nearly 3,000 people have
recovered so far so far there is a lower
death rate with coronavirus than with
SARS the death rate is about two percent
with SARS it was about 10 to 15 percent
but the number of infections is
significantly larger and more than
likely it's going to end up killing many
more people very very sad what's going
on and certainly any time a government
works to cover something up rather than
to actually deal with it it is
concerning for the entire world as we
are quickly seeing cases start to spread
all over the world